okay I mean we've looked at these well
we looked at these and we said let's
make these changes and then do some more
review so okay do you really want to use
script letters and things here for
things like angle bisectors and did we
we is this finalized a format for
display format for these things is that
finalized we had a meeting with the
graphics people this pass so that then
okay but that's like we're at the
eleventh hour here yes how come that
didn't happen and there was there a
reason good okay so that's bad so you
need to hop on that today who's doing
project management for this there isn't
really that's where we ran into a
problem here because that's a cross
group coordination thing so is there
some project manager in this meeting
okay so can you please hop on this today
and try and get this handled get these
guys to meet with graphic design I mean
if necessary we'll get the graphic
design folk in this very meeting
although I prefer not think that's gonna
get us even further behind here no I
mean we have we have at least three new
functions which ones which ones travel
center triangle construct and triangle
measurement all used to be triangle data
yeah well I think we agreed them on the
fact that they will be moved
into these separate functions which i
think is good um and also fine geometric
scene instance has become random
instance you should take a look at that
okay I mean this guide page should
probably be laid out a little bit more
extensively with more description of
what these things are um rather than
just all put in a list like this but
this is a perfectly good start for
reviewing right how I would do the
documentation I would have both cases in
the usage message so one decision we
made for the triangle centers were
having triangle Center returns a list of
coordinates whereas triangle construct
which takes can take similar inputs
returns point head for things at at
points
it makes decent sense to me but I mean
so if I were to to just put this in here
is there a default Center or not default
Center type I thought we were going to
have centroid be the default but I think
centroid should be the one argument form
here okay you can do that that's an
older breadth page not sure how old well
I just updated my document 800 no this
didn't did wait a minute is this coming
from your know that this is the actual
yeah that's the actual documentation
page so I just updated documentation
like within the last hour I did but not
okay okay so I'm just gonna give you
various pointers here so that this
should have the one argument form you
should have this triangle form or you
know say tri or something like that or
triangle here and then say in the notes
here you you can't have this secondary
form inconsistent with this here all
right so you either gonna say triangle
center of triangle comma Center okay
I'll get what I'm saying yes if you
understand okay um
triangle altitude that was a thing yeah
this is a very old breath page and it's
not what shows up for me yeah I don't
understand that so so we better figure
out what's going on at ASAP so when you
say it's very old
is this some so this is in my current
documentation build so I can go ahead
and update the documentation build but
that was this is an update but I already
did like an hour ago
so I can go ahead and do it again so
that it pulls anything in
I did in fact pull em triangle
measurement and triangle construct they
told in a bunch of these things so I
think you would just start editing very
recently okay I'd still that's still the
same so something went wrong here so
you've committed the wrong thing somehow
make sense hello yeah I'm trying to
figure out okay don't do you don't need
to figure it out right now I won't edit
this page right now okay so something is
wrong though okay so what did you want
to say about triangle altitude is that
still there or not
no okay so that's just triangle
construct should be there correct yes
okay so something went wrong with this
page so in the case of I don't quite
understand it in the case of altitude
what's P here oh I see P and then I see
Q 1 P Q 2 so the the key point is the
middle point there but now if if you can
give the triangle okay can you give a
triangle as a triangle object here yes a
new triangle for a yarn or just Alyssa
points okay but then then it's the it's
the middle of those points that is the
critical one for determining what
construct we're talking about is that
correct
all right correct in the contracts that
require that this or are you not a
reasonable convention for what happens
with is that going to work okay with
them in all cases to have that just be
the middle one of the of the of the
triangle
yeah if you want to specify if you don't
want it to be the middle one you can
make spec a list argue man nope nope
nope you don't get to do that you didn't
say it up here that's in quotes up here
you can't do that I'm making sense if
there was change to just the symbol spec
would it be fine
it's okay yeah yes but but you have to
write you have to get this right and
that's the wrong font by the way down
there right and and I would it's not
obvious to me that you want to say spec
that list whether you I guess it's okay
to have a peer list what's this
to get a list to get a list of
corresponding to each vertex what is
that oh by the way this is just not the
way this kind of government ation is
written I mean I mean I I haven't
confident Charles hasn't looked at this
so I don't think anybody who knows has
looked at this yet okay well if that's
the case that it's surprisingly good
okay you did ask me some questions early
on so I did give them some of the basics
okay all right okay so what is that case
they're sent a comma or what is that
case by the way that the formatting is
just completely wrong here so please
make sure you know how to do that right
practice who is actually writing this
stuff
I am Ian okay okay what does this case
mean please there should be a list of
three cbons one for each vertex so
what's the center thing doing here the
way you define a sieve Ian is you have a
vertex and then a center point and you
draw the line starting from the vertex
through that center point okay all right
fine all right so it's a it's a detailed
case for that particular so you should
have that structure
here where you say if one of these you
know when you say through the point P
opposite from P you should say XO Center
comma P right so people know the
structure I'm making sense
so it center of circum circle is just
circumcenter but then here when there's
an argument you should give it in this
list this is through the P form yeah
there's the P and then there's the
center yeah I see so depicted I mean yes
I agreed that third or some work here
you know post freeze I can meet with Ian
and help okay fine no a 9-point should
be as an adjective or phrase so it
should be hyphenated but that's a very
minor point okay um so if I say triangle
all right great right what what else
should we be looking at here so those
are things we agreed on
um the region centroid already exists
that's just a little support yep okay so
in sphere does that already exist yes
that already exists okay okay I'm not
existed correct a lot of the ones here
are things which you know will just
serve you know stay under valuated I'm
given a symbolic thing yes
the only exceptions is that currently I
don't know if if this is been updated in
the prototype build is the infinite line
and half line run into trouble because
of that if it just sees a list of two
symbols it assumes it's a vector and it
will add in the zero zero starting point
which has given us trouble which is why
we had
some holds around geometric scene that
we'd like to get rid of but we discussed
you removed us right I checked in
today's Pro not have a still to the Auto
evaluation no it's something ok listen
that this in a perfect world this would
do scoping for those variables what do
you mean but this this would be a
scoping construct right so those would
turn green but do you want is to give
attribute what do you mean this table to
dress all right okay so this so it will
end up being but these things can be
anything right they don't have to be
symbols they can be strings and things
as well right correct
they can also yes they can be and you
can also specify if you want to specify
some of them had particular coordinates
give you that up there but yeah they can
be anything
how can you specify them a particular
coordinate so if you can if you want a
to be at the origin you do a aro 0 comma
0 okay fair enough that's perfectly nice
ok so if I say random instance percent
24 comma 5 for example Oh God why is it
putting this stupid tabview thing no it
should default to a list like every
other random blah comma 5 thing does am
I making sense yeah no no actually not
in traumatic scene because you want to
have one scene with different
realizations on which you then perform
reasoning I see right so if you do input
form this will thought geometric scene
had if we're thinking of this is you
know the start of a general function
that would be quite weird for it to
return a list of things in some cases
and right oh yeah if this or if this
random
since is generalize I think this would
be very very weird so that won't work
because random instance with a name like
that is intended to be generalized and
how does returning a list prevent you
from doing it you're further reasoning
what Michael last time I propose that if
you want a nice view then we shouldn't
produce it your matrix in viewer or
something like that which typeset nicely
but this output should be a list
otherwise we cannot use it anywhere else
what do you mean by anywhere else
well sorry about random instance implied
the things that aren't geometric saying
yeah it won't work to have this not be a
list but the question is how one should
get this then it's very clumsy to carry
it around and do something with it
no but somebody can generate a list and
you have a geometric seen viewer which
type certain generated nicely like we
have you know highlighting for show more
such a thing so I don't get this easily
it isn't it's not a list it should be
less immediately so so Michael I mean if
it's not a list then you can't do random
instance of whatever comma 100 and scan
through easily for the one that you're
interested this still has to extract
that will take the list of things and
squish them into one geometric scene for
example just taking just wrapping
geometric scene around it if you want a
composite geometric scene each
individual one is a geometric scene
correct correct okay so then what I
think we should do is just say okay if
you want to get the composite geometric
scene you could always say geometric
scene of a bunch of geometric scenes but
but really this is not a composite of
geometric scene
just want to visualize nicely set of
genetics in no so how do you manipulate
composite of genetics in what do you do
with their reasoning about the
connectors yeah the idea is when we run
the conjecture code it looks it makes
the conjectures for each of these
individual instances and then takes the
intersection of all the conjectures why
did that not work the output of panties
so we don't reasoning we don't make
connectors for scenes we may conjectures
for instances of scenes right so if you
put in one of those ones you actually
yeah what's the difference so this we
were getting we were changing the
formatting for if you want to look at
the conjectures you can do what you in
input line 29 do a sub value of string
conjectures or conclusions conclusions
conclusions
I didn't image there's no cut there's no
contact her routine things right there
is nothing interesting in that you know
I don't understand why the conjectures
come from the original set of assertions
not from this particular random instance
right
no it's from this particular random
instance take another two year to write
we have the approver which is a few few
releases away there were many releases
away that reasons from the original from
the original what else does this do
fine fine geometric and yet what does it
do so it looks at the concrete
coordinates returned by each instance
and then we'll we'll list the
interesting things that happen to be
true about that same it seems really is
that useful
I mean I've think nothing else is really
feasible like like assume you don't do
it this way and you do it algebraically
you get you get a guy dentures ideal of
polynomials that has no meaning to you
yeah but so what's the case where this
would work that they do Bailey's theorem
so geometric seen have circled flew to
me but I mean so there's a case where
basically it will be there are facts
that are true of every instance and it
will then give you a symbolic
representation of those facts that are
true of every instance is that true yes
and so in this particular case this
construction didn't have any interesting
facts that were true of every instance
even though obviously the original facts
like there's a circle through you know a
Knicks are projected out yeah yeah we
ignore those if the user supplies them
okay fine okay I guess an interesting
question would be if you instead of
doing five if you did one right if you
found one instance and ran fine
geometric conjectures if it would give
you something I mean it would probably
be completely meaningless well I didn't
do that I didn't I didn't didn't no no
that's what I did right no no I didn't I
was looking at the individual case oh so
for the contractor code now we only like
a fan conductor for like three well
things like equal angles Nikolas and
regular polygons similar triangles
ah so in this graph we don't have any
okay but were I to do something I mean I
can't easily construct it myself if I
were to say I think there should be
examples in the geometric scene right
here presumably and find geometric
conjectures that there would be an
example but before this went uh I
understand there are no examples here
put example in this person about this is
exactly the case that you said didn't
work uh yeah that's why the this is old
behavior and I haven't updated examples
or tried adding anymore because thinking
okay so in this case here if I said
random instance here right that was
they'll do what you and also you need to
update midpoint to be a list midpoint of
list a comma C and then you need to take
this sub value since that we've been
changing the conclusions so we have the
cool yeah
planar angle of ABC is they conclude
equals 90 is the conclusion of Bailey's
theorem that's very cool so yes it's
also very weird to explain to people you
have to take a random instance first if
you Toby can do something different but
yeah well why don't you just do this
have fine geometric conjectures
automatically do a random instance
inside it's just too incomprehensible to
do it without that we did that in the
past but the thing is there could be
cases like the internal graph is a
degenerate graph and and sometimes it
may be a bad graph and you find a lot of
contractors but they are not true
because so then take the intersection as
ones that are true for like three I mean
make you know fine geometric conjectures
try three random instances and take the
intersection of the conjectures that are
true about them yes the contractor could
come work on that but is also how the
probability you take like three random
instance and one of them has a bell
graph and it returns
now after conductors and then
intersections and what do you mean by a
bad go of how could it be how could it
be what what what could
happen all the points can not crash
together but so what so what so then it
will what what will it do will it fail
to find it we all find an empty list
right all the points will be right next
to each other and it won't be able won't
be able to do so uh
this is way too obscure having to put
random instance inside there is way too
obscure so we'd be better off just
having fine geometric conjectures used
some appropriate heuristic to do the
best it can than having it be um than
having it do this you know basically
what you're saying is well you know well
if the user did three and didn't bother
to look at the other two and they'll get
the wrong answer anyway
exactly no you three don't get the phone
well look listen listen
put in some heuristic that is as
reasonable as you can to find geometric
conjectures it's a fine function find
functions don't necessarily succeed I
assume random seating so that you get
the same answer every time right right
and it's and it's also called conjecture
I mean I could conjecture that we'll be
ready to ship tomorrow to disprove but I
can still make that conjecture yeah okay
all right yes I agree so okay but did
that went [ __ ] quick pass to quickly
random seating is set to a fixed number
like 1 2 3 4 correct yes okay all right
so look with respect to random instance
we have got to make this just return a
list ok so if you want to make it so
that if you give geometric seeing a list
of geometric scenes it will make a
combined one so be it
all right I think currently do this for
identical Givens yes I assume so
otherwise would give an error message
right okay just to be clear so I'm at
random and since give that sub value
stream
instances and let's make sure that's
exactly what you want so I think that's
the behavior we have that matches what
you want so uh no no the afterwards
although actually met you tried this
with multiple with the five right so we
have a list one you know
magnificent just what we need okay so
let's look at geometric assertion
I think we've looked at this before
right right which was so at this point
what's the difference between find
instance and find again well I guess
find instance takes a assertion it's a
little different so there's so a little
confusing right yeah I think the idea
was find instance is deterministic and
random instances not yea --except that
it is because we're gonna have a fixed
random seed in that's right well maybe
not for random and no random instance
will not have a fixed seat sorry random
instance should not have a fixed seat
find geometric conjectures should have a
fixed seed yeah I see okay but ranked
geometric conjectures would have a SUP
option that would be the seating the
seating would not be a top-level option
because later on we hopefully don't need
it anymore well you could give a random
seating option okay fine
method okay that's what well you could
put it in the method option for find
your let's inject race yeah okay that's
fine um okay so uh please make sure and
send me mail later on today with what
you've come up with with design for the
design of these things hey um okay what
else should we look at here ah the time
we have this quite lovely I mean there's
there's a lot of great stuff in what was
I just looking at
I was just looking at geometric
assertion why does it wise clockwise
polygon just clockwise did we look at
this before yes so they are I see these
because you say I've given object there
so the object is polygon you say
geometric insertion assertion then you
give the polygon symbolically and then
you say comma clockwise yes uhm I think
you might want to distinguish the
polygon assertions from the non polygon
and oh we that should go away yeah
so just elsewhere you can specify an
independent point is one where are the
set of points where you can where you
give it just random values at the start
and the other points and it can't
conflict with anything later on it's
just if the user knows that some points
are can be independently assigned
coordinates then it will speed up the
computation look at the options two
geometric scene yeah okay hold on but I
think this should be in a list these
multi property things
we think it's like style I see can you
support them in a list as well well
because right that was I think that was
why we changed from list to sequence
because some of these properties require
extra specification well a little bit
you're doing that with these rules you
know that should be a list sorry yeah
[Music]
all right okay okay are we going to have
I mean not not for right now but NLU
capabilities with these geometric
specifications one day okay natural
language oh okay what else should we
make sure to look at here I really think
this is all quite lovely and as an
experimental set of features I think
it's it's quite fine um
you look at the options to geometric
scene yes sure will cool off a bit
the very last thing okay so that was
independent variables when the opposite
to the dependent 144 linear equations so
wait a minute so we that's a new concept
to have a thing called independent
variables yes
what other functions could have it and
we can have that in zillions of other
functions in algebra and so on couldn't
we dissolve all the it's kind of the
natural I would think so why do we need
to give these as an option here it's a
little bit like it fine sorry
in these solve you declare right we have
one place for the deep in the
and variables in one place for the
dependent variables yes but like like if
we wanted to become convenient like in
alpha ability now body types in
independent variable people type by 2 by
2 pi and plus y so if you would be
declaring independent variables it might
be a nice feature for quick inputs right
but why do we need to declare them here
it's a little bit like inside
distribution like time distributions for
many real-life examples you need to give
some help it's approximately the
parameter range you're looking for for
complicated distribution when similar
here if you know that the certain set of
points are independent it's a somatic
help for the for the ongoing nationally
what do you mean by independent there's
no mutual constraint between them is
that what you mean by independent
variables in other cases no not really
I think that many meanings of the larger
sorry I'm saying that there are many
different meanings yeah of independent
independent it's it's context dependent
right but so here this is saying these
points can be arbitrarily placed they
are independent yes right correlation 0
yeah that's not the same thing no that's
a that will be an ensemble statement
this is certainly not this is simply a
statement that these are algebraically
independent in some sense
the correlation and independence is not
the same except for normals so it's a
it's a statement about the rank of the
corresponding algebraic system yes okay
so look I I'm not a big fan of that name
and I'm not a big I mean is this an
efficiency thing to be able to give this
yes is Wiegand if we want to do away
with it for now it's not gonna to things
what is the efficiency thing but this
one also allows if you wanted to
manipulate it
they are very natural candidates for the
manipulation variables because this
think mostly is the continuous function
of these things yeah dependent one day
that's nearly hopeless making it
dependent because you switch on dress
well why are we calling them variables
these are essentially the symbolic point
symbolic representations of points they
could also be radii we allow symbolic
scalar quantities for instance for radii
so is this something that the user would
mostly input or is this something that
the geometric scene can generate yeah
eventually I can create a dependency
graph and and figure out but for now to
see their input right so we're not made
we we're not assuming that any points
have this special property where they're
not interdependent on everything else
the computation will try to make
everything consistent right wait so
you're saying that like I guess I still
don't quite understand then what it's
doing if I have a line of a B and the
line of B C and then I say is an
independent variable what does that mean
that means that so the the random
instance creates a problem for fine
minimum if you say if you list something
as an independent variable rather than
plugging that as a variable in the fine
minimum it will beforehand just assign
that a random value and it's just a you
know and so fine minimum has one less
thing to worry about like if you would
have to seen and you would read it in a
manipulate you could freely move this
point around and things to generically
not jump right well okay so no
quantities would be worse I mean three
variables that those will mean all kinds
of elaborate things um what's the
argument structure of this guy it's a
bit like for me like checked symbols in
manipulate yes means these are hardly
variables by the way because making like
strings and so like that store what
another syntax like you know who goes to
empty list or something unless unless
this refers to things which aren't
declared but it might be nice to polka
medically given a scene they investigate
dependents who to trust change options
overseeing cause of the investor for
your arguments doctor I mean looking but
eventually you're gonna want that
independence independent you know which
parameters are independent being
programmatically determinable right
now yes and no there aren't
there's not a unique solution there
might be different sets of independent
even worse so that you choose one like
that's right the user can give one right
I understand
calling these things variables is a mess
come on need a kit um or you've split up
two independent points and independent
quantities what are these conclusions
about the scene how are they represented
those conclusion things so those are
they when you ran them fine geometric
conjectures comes up as a geometric
assertion right in the scene language in
exactly the same way hypothesis carry
right but in particular
well I'm thinking is that geometric
assertion could have a property that
means I'm independent that's all we had
previously and see that gets ugly
because oh that's what that independent
point thing is yeah that was that was
what that was in there I think it's
nicer if is the option because one might
want to manipulate them quickly rather
than manipulating the whole first
argument and second also i conceptually
don't think that makes much sense which
this is asserting that a point is
independent like equilateral that's
something that you can verify it's
either true or false verifying that
something is independent really yours
you're telling the solver to treat it as
independent well so really this is
writing your coordinate system so to
speak so is this here theorems that
start with for any three points x y&z
you construct this and blah blah blah
pretty much so this
really unconstrained yes parameters or
something yeah yeah I think I could live
with an option named unconstrained
parameters I think that's a Roger can
you think of mean this is a new and
different case because this is an
essential more symbolic than a lot of
things we've been dealing with
previously yeah I mean yes I think it's
it's fine
I mean it would the problem with
independent variables is that it has so
many entanglements like oh I did devote
variable is a mess in the language so we
don't have to add to it right so what
unconstrained parameters I like it all
right now okay
all right anything else we should look
at here otherwise we've got lots of
stuff to push on and you know we'll look
at the and Michael will have a chance to
look at this documentation in a bit
although it's really doesn't look in
terrible shape it's just you know
details um well maybe I should take this
I'm still confused by Michael statement
that there could be multiple things it
seems to me like either you've had
enough assertions that you've
constrained a variable or you haven't
I'm confused by this let's assume you
have risk you have a quadrilateral and
there's three degrees of freedom then
you can say I want a PC independent all
you want PCD independent I think there's
a unique choice of independent ones it's
like like a PI own realization of
ricotta bases okay
okay excellent lovely stuff all right
okay okay